[Music]
somewhere in the universe is a small
blue planet the third Rock from a star
called the Sun just one of billions of
stars in a spiral galaxy known as the
Milky Way but where in the universe is
the Milky Way a team of scientists
gather data on more than 8,000 of the
galaxies that surround us they mapped
each galaxies position and movement in
space and for the first time they've
shown that the Milky Way is part of a
much larger system of galaxies a super
cluster that they have named Laniakea
the Milky Way is nested in the furthest
reaches of this structure on the
outskirts
[Music]
the entire universe can be seen as an
intricate network of galaxies a cosmic
web some areas are almost empty dark
voids others are densely packed with
galaxies in regions known as super
clusters super clusters are the biggest
structures found in the universe but
scientists have struggled to define
where one ends and another begins
to map our home super cluster a team led
by Brent Tully at the University of
Hawaii studied the motions of the
galaxies around us in unprecedented
detail even though the entire universe
is expanding rapidly gravity is also at
work pulling against this acceleration
by discounting cosmic expansion the team
worked out which galaxies are being
pulled towards us shown in blue and
which are being pulled away shown in red
this enabled them to create a map of
cosmic flows the paths that galaxies
migrate along targeted a tiny pace by
the force of gravity using this motion
they came up with a new way to map the
distribution of matter in the universe
delving into a home super cluster you
can see that most galaxies are being
pulled towards a dense Center this is
known as the Great Attractor our galaxy
is among those sliding towards this
patch of space which dominates our
region of the universe let's take a
different view
each circle represents a galaxy again we
can see most galaxies being pulled
towards the Great Attractor in the
direction of the arrows between the
Great Attractor in us the Milky Way is a
relatively empty area a blue void and
next to us is Virgo a large and dense
cluster whose bright galaxies have been
observed from Earth for centuries until
now astronomers grouped us the Milky Way
and its surrounding galaxies with Virgo
and nearly a hundred other clusters in a
super cluster that stretches a hundred
million light-years across
but using this new technique we can see
that this is just the tip of the iceberg
this cluster of clusters is merely an
appendage of a much larger super cluster
more than 100 times bigger and more
massive how did the team know how to
redraw the boundaries of this cosmic map
here's our super cluster in black and a
neighboring structure Perseus Pisces in
red scientists defined the boundary as
the points where the flows of galaxies
diverge like water dividing at a
watershed this is where neighboring
structures share apart this is the first
clear definition of a super cluster
Laniakea means immeasurable heav'n in
Hawaiian a fitting name for the vast
community of galaxies that we are a part
of so now we know that on the edge of a
super cluster would Laniakea in a galaxy
called the Milky Way around a star we
call the Sun there is a small blue
planet our home
[Music]